welcome everybody it is that time once
again we are minutes two hours away from
today's White House press briefing on
coronavirus what are we expecting today
one of the things we are expecting today
as the feed goes live and we should get
a look in the room and how soon this may
start Oh it's outdoors today
oh very interesting one of the things
we're expecting today maybe is the
announcement of who will be on Trump's
Council to reopen America yesterday it
was reported that Jared and Ivanka were
on it although yesterday when Trump was
asked about a task force he said they're
not on it is the council the same thing
as the task force we just don't know we
just don't know and of course yesterday
we had the most authoritarian of any
White House press briefing that we've
seen so far I will get that momentarily
we also are expecting some time this
week and we don't yet know which day
Trump said it would be soon and it would
be this week the plan for the early
stages of opening the country and of
course this is increasingly becoming a
battle of who has the right to
ultimately decide what happens within a
state is it governors or is it Trump
I'll give you a hint this thing called
the Constitution tells us it's not Trump
let's look a little bit at some clips
from yesterday again these are arguably
the most if their authority Arian
moments that we've ever seen from Donald
Trump claiming to have absolute
authority take a look what you're trying
no not at all let me just a very simple
I'm gonna put it very simply the
President of the United States has the
authority to do what the president has
the authority to do which is very
powerful the President of the United
States calls the shots if we weren't
here for the States
you would have had a problem in this
country like you've never seen before
well and if he had appointed an Ebola
coronavirus star like Obama had an Ebola
czar we'd be much better off we're here
to back them up and we're back and we've
more than backed them up we did a job
that nobody ever thought was possible
it's a decision for the president the
United States now with that being said
we're gonna work with the states because
it's very important you have local
governments they're pinpointed it's
really you talk about it's a like a
microchip they're pinpointed you have
the microchip comment is lunacy local
government that hopefully will do a good
job and if they don't do a good job I'd
step in so fast but no they can't do
anything without the approval of the
president now let's think this through
on a couple different levels
first of all does a governor even have
the power to force a business to open no
no can the governor of Massachusetts say
you know whatever someone's deli
restaurant you must open today no it's a
private business can can the governor
say we are opening state schools okay
now we're talking about something can
the president tell a governor that they
must mandate restaurants open for
example of course not of course not and
this is really it's a constitution they
can say it exactly they can say it as
people in the chat are saying but they
can't force it to happen police aren't
going to show up at your local Chinese
restaurant and say you must open
scallion pancakes now or you are going
to prison like obviously that would
never happen but it really comes down to
the Constitution anything that is not
specific I sound like a small government
conservative the this is normally what
the government small government
conservatives say if the Constitution
doesn't specifically say that the
federal government has X power the
federal government does not have that
power and this is a type of admits
administration that is solely in the
hands of the states many state governors
already coming together and making
alliances so that everybody does the
same thing at the same time because that
makes sense if New York there's one
thing in New Jersey does a different one
infections will just spread back and
forth it doesn't make sense and so Trump
being circumvented some people it's a
very ugly phrase it's very strong
language but some would say that Trump
is being cucked
by governor's I would never say that
this is a program where we don't use
that type of language but one could say
that like on people maybe on
twitch would say something like that by
the way hi to everybody on Twitch love
you guys and thanks to I am Compu bear
for the support but in any case so this
is delusional we have a president who
wants to be a dictator is incredibly
authoritarian and is just wrong about
the power that he claims to have that he
claims to have if you are watching on
Twitter twitch Facebook or YouTube which
is everybody because those are the only
places were broadcasting today's press
briefing scheduled for 5:00 p.m. Eastern
at it's three minutes past the hour and
we are waiting waiting for what may be
big announcements we just don't know
will we hear about Trump's counsel to
reopen America will we hear early ideas
from Trump about reopening at this point
it really seems like we're looking at
minimum at may 15 for for anything and
there's a very good actually let me see
if I can find it this will just take me
a moment because I did not have it handy
there is a very good analysis from where
is it oh here it is okay who is this is
from like a big financial firm actually
and and sometimes when money is on the
line you can count on sometimes good
analyses this is a possible roadmap of
what things may look like and this is
relatively detailed and what we are
looking at here number one what's
important about this is that it has two
different lines for the east and west
coast epicenters in the US versus the
rest of the US which may have different
peaks that's a really important thing to
consider this suggests in this possible
roadmap that by the end of this month we
need to be testing 500,000 a day by the
end of May we need to be testing a
million a day by June there would be
serology testing which would allow you
to see who has been infected and
recovered and according to this the
early infected could return to work in
June this would be wave one looks like
it's around June 15 that they're
suggesting and
mid-summer you could have waved to
returning to work which would presumably
be people who are at less risk younger
people maybe the next wave of people who
have recovered etc this includes a
potential second wave of infection
starting right around election time
interestingly enough whoo that's good
for I don't know this is the the path of
the possible second wave and importantly
there's the idea now that if there's an
early efficacy signal for a vaccine and
dr. fowey has talked about this that
vaccine may be made available to
healthcare workers as early as October
15th and then the vaccine would likely
be available more broadly right now
looking at March 15 of 2021 nearly
that's 11 months away so this is a
really interesting roadmap for me
because it is optimistic in some
elements like the early healthcare
availability of a vaccine it is cautious
in other ways where it says nobody
should go back to work
until June and then it should only be
the people who were first infected which
really isn't that bene right but again
this is key you have to have the
antibody test because if you look at the
official numbers right now okay 600,000
people going back to work doesn't do
that much when seventeen million just
filed for unemployment right it's it's a
drop in the bucket if we had the
serology test if the real number of
infected was 5 million 10 million 50 we
just don't know that's something that's
more significant in terms of of getting
back to work so that's a really
interesting Road rap it's from some
financial firm it might be it might be
Morgan Stanley it might be Morgan
Stanley actually so feel free to check
that out and look at it in detail
yourselves if you're just joining on
twitch or YouTube make sure to like
follow subscribe like follow subscribe
or things that are variably available on
those different platforms let me look at
a few of these super chats that have
come in so far super chat is via YouTube
and your message will pop up in the
bottom left there Seth Barham says hey
David where are the states rights
conservatives after yesterday
absolutely Seth I you know made that
point didn't see your super chat until
now
Donna Williams says Trump is so awful in
public imagine what he's like behind
closed doors
horeb horrifying I appreciate your
channel David Daniel Rivera says thanks
for helping us sound smarter to our
friends thanks my pleasure Daniel mr.
vill boo and Amber Morris have grabbed
YouTube subscriptions James Bret sends a
super chat joke rockin berg says how far
away are we from stimulus package for we
don't know yet Trump mentioned that to
minuchin yesterday but but we don't we
don't know Mary Allen says at what point
can he be hospitalized for 72 hours
psychiatric evaluation assuming you're
talking about Trump I wouldn't hold my
breath if it hasn't happened already I
don't know that it's going to rob Koppel
says everybody pray with me for a huge
gust of wind that messes up Trump's hair
Zach Bushman says to what extent do you
think ant abide in rhetoric from the
populist left is coming from trumpets
and/or Russians especially on reddit
many appear to be it's it's nonzero but
I don't know you know I don't want to
get into this stuff where I say anyone
criticizing Biden on reddit is really a
Russian troll because obviously that's
not true I don't know I don't know what
percentage it is I really don't we have
a hype train happening on Twitch which
is always very exciting we've missed the
hype trains in recent streams but there
is certainly one happening today the
purple party of Canada says the anti dem
left needs to approach anti Trump right
and form two new parties both sides are
afraid to start a new party start one
for each balance listen unless we have
some other kind of electoral system or a
proportional representation system the
risk to doing that is significant and
that's part of why you don't see larger
efforts to do it I actually did an
interview on today's broadcast show with
the great AC grayling and we talked
about exactly that issue I hope that
you'll check it out
Nick Carter says big fan of the show
keep up the great work wishing health
and wellness to everyone during these
times especially those with mental
health issues absolutely unknown prodigy
says do your friends call you David
highschool friends tend to call me Dave
everyone I met from college on or pre
middle school tends to call me david KW
b says thoughts on more than two major
parties i can see many benefits
ultimately i think it makes it easier
for people like trump to get elected
again i've got a lot of clips about that
on my youtube channel and there is some
truth to that nasty questions says how
late will this press briefing begin I
wish I could just fast-forward to the
nasty questions thanks Deepak for
streaming every day
Veronica kolinsky says Trump saying a
lot should be on the bingo sheet yeah
I'm gonna go back to bingo tomorrow I
want to update the bingo card and I'm
gonna go back to it tomorrow so
something very very exciting to look
forward to leverne ver nth Verret Lee
verad sorry says do you think Trump will
do something to suspend the general
election he really can't it's up to the
state's legal eagle has a good video
explaining what would or could happen I
haven't seen it I assume the focuses we
really have 50 individual elections in
this country it's ultimately up to the
states ryan nawicki says leaded gas was
used in 40 years that account for most
of our representatives upbringing how
impactful would you guess this has been
in politics you know you'd really have
to talk to an epidemiologist about that
I don't know but it is an interesting
question
Michelle why Splott Dame says could not
have gotten through this without you
keep it up Thank You Michelle so
appreciate your support Ollie says stay
at home order four foul Qi will be house
arrest jamal swift hey homie tightening
bootstraps a bit so we'll pause patreon
for a bit but we'll give here to
continue to support appreciate your work
I understand Jamal I understand what's
going on and so unfortunately what in
late March and early April was a 35
percent decline in YouTube revenue has
escalated to about 45 percent and it's
it's just tough out there and you know
advertisers are buying fewer ads on
YouTube that brings down how much we
make so everybody's struggling and as I
said we lost about
a 300 389 not about we had three hundred
and eighty nine members canceled in
March paid members that's a lot for us
and over a hundred already in April and
we're halfway through April and so the
the if you are not down to your last
dollar and you appreciate the streams
and you want to support us a little bit
consider sending a pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show
we have 1783 patrons right now this is
really easy it's quick it takes a second
we've got a very modest goal of 25
patrons today the website is patreon.com
slash david pakman show and in fact i
think we already have a couple of
patrons who i want to thank all thank
everybody john spencer is patron number
one today and david Lanier is patron
number two so I appreciate that and
jamol I feel for you and listen that we
are not food rent a vehicle you know
mortgage the electrical bill we are not
that so I don't want anybody's you know
gas money or whatever but for the folks
that are able to support us even at a
dollar a month and you can pick your
level of support on patreon it's so
appreciated because we are down now a
close to 500 paid subscribers as a
result of what's going on and we're not
special in any way right everybody
everybody's challenged by what is going
on let me say thanks to Krug's or or
subscribing with twitch prime also want
to say thanks to Bill iam 598 for
subscribing with twitch prime very very
much appreciated Shawn King says David I
want pancakes I made pancakes over the
weekend I've been cooking a lot made a
beautiful beautiful set of blueberry
pancakes and I see people asking about
my garden it is getting going I built
some garden beds over the weekend you
can follow the adventure on my Instagram
David Pakman and I'm about to plant I
called for a topsoil delivery today as
soon as that's in I'm going to be able
to plant what can I plant outdoors I can
plant carrots radish
various spinach --is and lettuces what
else
and then indoors I'm planting herbs
tomatoes us what else and some spicy
thin peppers and then around Mother's
Day we move those outside it's a
beautiful thing it's all happening and
it's all very very alpha behavior as all
of you can imagine pictures and video of
all of this are on my Instagram feed
Thomas Powell says USA TODAY's stream
was live fact-checking last night good
for them good for them I've been saying
that they must do it and I've been
saying it for a while Klaus gray blur
says if Trump could do anything to
impress you what would it be
resign admit that he's in over his head
and resign J Mora says is a bingo
t-shirt possible love your work DP
that's an interesting idea we could take
the the bingo board the Trump bingo
board and make it a t-shirt that would
be very easy and quick to put together
that actually is an interesting idea
that I'm gonna look into very very
strongly let me say thank you to Joy
calfy who is patron number three today
francy pants Gonzales francy pants
Gonzales is new patron number four today
I want to thank bik bot for doubling
their pledge from ten to twenty bucks a
month I'm gonna count it as new patron
number five
Jeremy Cruz his new patron number six
today and Kellan Smith his new patron
number seven thank you very much I
really appreciate that support oh I had
a couple other videos though that I did
want to play for you let me see here oh
okay this was another great moment from
yesterday Trump played a propaganda
video yesterday where he bragged about
everything he did before we had our
first case and then he bragged about
everything we did in March and it's like
well what did you do from January 21
until March and the answer is a lot of
golf
Paula Reed from CBS beautifully crushing
Trump here and pointing out what
happened to February you skipped
February in the video Trump becomes
furious tells her she's fake all of that
stuff
you bought the argument is that you
bought yourself some time you didn't you
just to prepare hospitals you didn't use
it to ramp up testing so you so it's so
disgraceful the way you said it
let me just listen I just went over it I
just nobody thought we should do it and
what I did it what do you do when you
have no case in a whole United States
when you excuse me you reported it zero
cases zero deaths On January 17 now
Trump talking about the seventeenth is
very deceptive because on the 20th we
got our first case right so he talks
about January 17 and then he skips to
march well January 20 is when North
South Korea not North Korea South Korea
got their first case they developed a
test widespread testing they still have
under 250 deaths total that's not a typo
nah I don't mean today South Korea had
250 deaths total they don't have 250
deaths Trump skipping from January 17 to
March and in fact we'll give you a list
right Trump can't think of anything but
he's gonna generate a list but we did in
fact part of who was up there we did a
lot a lot you know you're a fake you
know that your whole network the way you
cover it is fake and most of it and not
all of you but the people are wise to
you that's why you have a lower lower
approval rating than you've ever had
before right it's the it's their
approval rating that's at issue here so
another completely dystopian moment
completely dystopian moment yesterday
during during the press briefing and we
will I wouldn't be surprised today
if Trump shows up with a piece of paper
and lists what was done in February now
that they've had 24 hours to concoct
something they won't mention Trump's
golfing
they won't mention Trump's minimizing of
the problem they won't mention Trump
saying we have 15 cases and it'll go to
zero
they won't mention from saying we have
zero deaths none of that will be
mentioned but I wouldn't be surprised
see Trump come out today with a with a
list of stuff to mention okay let me say
a few other thank-yous Frank Germond is
new patron number 8 today Graham Coleman
is new patron number 9 and Ellen
classica SP au is new patron number 10
at patreon.com slash david pakman show a
few other folks to thank mark angel is
new patron number 11 Eric Martin is new
patron number 12 MS BS Hutchings is new
patron number 13 and s Patterson is new
patron number 14 very very much
appreciate that support and we're more
than halfway there my friends thank you
okay Tania Clark whoops hold on a second
where did that go Tania Clark where did
that go
Jane Maura wait if Trump could do
anything bingo t-shirt Oh
tally Oh Divino hey David do you think
Trump genuinely believes in the fantasy
world he's created for himself or is he
totally aware of his lies I really don't
know the answer to that my opinion about
that change is almost daily I truly
don't know whether Trump has deluded
himself into believing a lot of his BS
or whether he knows that he's just lying
to people or where he believes he's
exaggerating but for the greater good a
lot of time these delusional narcissists
they don't think that they're telling
the the literal truth they don't believe
that they are lying completely they
believe that they are crafting a
narrative that is based in reality and
they justify it by saying I'm smarter
than everybody so it's for the greater
good that I'm exaggerating in these ways
often times that's how deluded the
narcissism itself causes them to have
that sort of delusional delusions of
grandeur essentially and it is
pathological in nature as many people in
the chat are pointing out Tonya Clark
says what are your thoughts on opening
schools as a public school teacher in
Florida
I'm sadly preparing to lose my job
rather than go on campus and risk
infection I think that the this semester
should just be done
I don't I don't actually know that
anyone's thinking of opening this
semester I've heard rumors but I've not
actually seen it if anybody is that's
crazy what we should be looking at is
the fall there are already many colleges
saying it's going to be online in the
fall and it's gonna be spring 2021 that
we reopen I defer to the medical experts
but right now seems crazy there's people
saying Liberty University is I mean
they're absolutely out of their minds
that wouldn't surprise me
Blanco Blanco 0 420 or Blanco 420 says
hey David you are performing a public
service thank you thank you my friend
erielle has subscribed on YouTube
Christy says what did you think of
Obama's Biden endorsement um I I mean
listen it's the it's the right thing to
do we need everyone's help to defeat
Trump and I'll have a deeper analysis of
it tomorrow I've only watched a couple
minutes of it and I want to watch the
full 12 minutes before I before I
comment in a serious manner let me say
thanks to mark Foucault who has
subscribed with twitch prime also card
this has subscribed with prime thanks to
both of you very much appreciated
Derrick Vandervoort says I got a secret
service recruitment ad on Spotify
yesterday I don't know whether to laugh
or cry
I I wouldn't know how to react myself
any ghost says would it be possible for
your team to produce a highlights video
from each press briefing featuring only
important facts and policies that are
announced you know we are so overloaded
with work and that I don't know that we
can really do I just don't know that we
have the bandwidth to do that Sarmatian
which i think means never jung-in French
will I get the full show with the $2
join stay safe know so if you want to
get the full commercial free show on
patreon that's it the $10 a month level
but you can always get a membership on
my website and every membership has the
full show so if the full show is your
big thing the cheapest way to get it is
on the website okay Ike Lewis says is
Trump trying to gauge support for a
dictator
not I don't know that he's consciously
doing it Jennifer Higgins says this
Trump have the ability to withhold
stimulus monies from states that do not
comply with his demands to return to
life as normal
he may be able to do that he may be able
to do that that may be his only sort of
uh crutch that he may use to gain
leverage on governors Evan Houston says
thoughts on Candice Owens and other
trumpets obvious obfuscation
and denial of the pandemic numbers you
know Candice blocked me years ago so I
don't know what she ever tweets I can't
she's blocked both my personal account
and our show accounts on Twitter so I
actually have no idea what she's saying
and you know it's really easy to win the
battle of ideas when you block people
from even seeing what your stupid ideas
are as they are very very stupid let me
say thank the ones I saw a year and a
half ago before she blocked me I want to
be clear about that Nikola Tesla is new
patron number 15 today thank you Lisa
Iguchi is new patron number 16 today
Chris Hill stay is new patron number 17
today Michael Sanchez is new patron
number 18
amber Morris is new patron number 19
thanks amber
and Nancy Schmitt is new patron number
20 I people are asking about the haircut
thing I did mention yesterday and I
don't know that I'm going to come to
regret this I mentioned yesterday that
if we were to get to 4,000 patrons I
would cut my hair live on stream as many
of you know I haven't shaved North cut
my hair for a long time now and I don't
know what the future of that holds I set
at 4,000 patrons I would I would just
cut my hair live on stream I don't think
is gonna happen I think we will be back
on to sort of a more I think I'll be
able to get a real haircut at a barber
shop or salon before we get to 4,000
patrons but who knows who knows
David Lee Cox says if you could ask
Trump anything and he had to tell the
truth what would it be oh well if he had
it would be you have no IDE
what you're doing do you Elise Fagan
says do you think these press
conferences do any good good for whom I
think is the question and the answers
would would depend on that crumble says
you're a treat Dave keep up the good
work thank you thank you so much and
remember it whether or not you send a
super chat you can support the YouTube
stream just by hitting like it's very
simple a lot you can hit the like button
a lot to quote the president you hit
like and subscribe and it yesterday a
lot of people did it and we had like 80
500 people on the stream because it's
directly correlated as what we've
noticed that's a term I got from Trump
correlation he knows all about it
kwik-e-mart says what do you do when you
have a tornado warning but no houses
knocked down and no lives lost the
logical answer is you go play golf yeah
it seems that that's what Trump did with
the virus Ben Taylor says hey David
starting to feel a bit depressed and
scared Kyle feels strongly that things
will never be the same again that we
will see a whole new way of life you
seem calm but are you worried I am yeah
I think that it I mean so so here's my
thought on that humans are incredibly
adaptable and I was just messaging with
a friend before starting the stream
where yesterday and today for the first
time this routine started feeling normal
to me it started feeling not like
something is weird to be doing the show
from home to wake up and work at home to
go out for a walk to be back at home to
go out for a run to be back at home do
the stream then I make dinner and like
it's it's all feeling more normal and
this is just proof of how much humans
adapt to horrible conditions to
different conditions whatever so I think
that when things start to go back to
normal there will be for a long time
things that remain maybe people won't
shake hands maybe we'll see masks in
public maybe we will not see big
sporting events for a really long time
people will still distance when they
pass each other on the sidewalks if
that's what they were doing now a lot
people you know aren't doing it some
people are going to crazy churches and
being on top of each other but I do
think eventually things will mostly go
back to the way they were it will
probably take years but even if they
don't it will feel like they did that's
the part I'm sure about which is
eventually things will feel normal even
if they don't actually go back because
humans are just so flexible by Nature
so to speak Matthew Roskill says what
are your thoughts on Bernie endorsing
Biden more quickly than he endorsed
Hillary if it scrolled past hold on in
2016 how irritated do you think she is
by this I have no idea you know I find
myself devoting no thought to Hillary
Clinton lately Megan Gaddis says do you
think the housing market will go down
and when so I believe that the I don't I
I'm terrible I don't even pretend to
make economic predictions but if you put
a gun to my head my instinct is that the
housing markets as they are are very
tiered so you will sometimes have like
the general housing market in a slump
but the luxury housing market does fine
for example or you can have the condo
market go one way in the housing of the
single-family home market go differently
or it can be regionalised or it can be
urban versus rural from what I know
we're already seeing some depression in
some elements for lack of a better term
of the housing market and not in others
and I would assume that that will
continue but speaking to my realtor
friends they say they'll they're still
doing pretty good business here in
Boston that there's no open houses it's
all private showings and people are
careful you know to touch as little as
possible they wear gloves and that sort
of thing but I period I don't have any
other sort of special knowledge that I'd
be able to contribute to that let me say
thank you to alison krauss who is new
patron number 21 today at patreon.com
slash david pakman show i early
appreciate the folks that have been
supporting us and we've lost a lot of
support because of what's going on the
streams have brought in new supporters
it's helping to keep us close to level
and I really do appreciate it I also
appreciate our Twitter supporters like
crown Paul
who just subscribed with twitch Prime
Lenny Raymer sends a super chat david
pakman Germany branch office
headquarters says hey David do you agree
journalists are leaning to ask our
learning to ask smarter and sharper
questions on Trump day-to-day I don't
know that it's that journalists are
learning to ask sharper questions I
think journalists are deciding what the
hell I'm just going to ask it because it
just makes sense and the worst that can
happen is I don't get invited to these
harebrained press conferences any more
CS Patterson says I have a membership
just signed up on patreon wow I really
appreciate it membership patreon and
super chat support Thomas says the
American people should sue Trump I think
we should just vote him out in November
Alex Koepke says conservative here
rarely agree with you watch everyday
here's some money keep up the good work
I really appreciate that Alex even a
conservative it's throwing five bucks
our way david Tillery says I'm better at
debating my position in political
discussions as a result of watching your
show I really appreciate everything you
guys do thank you David and the whole
David Pakman show crew so appreciate it
David thank you
Don Hall has upgraded their membership
Austin Clark says Utah today announced
school closure rest of year yeah I think
that makes sense I think it's crazy to
think about going back to school this
year I just it does make any sense to me
whatsoever
Keaton Klepper says Dave should Trump
pardon the Scranton strangler I know
very little about that case very very
little but so everybody's talking about
Tiger King okay I'm gonna recommend for
you a different documentary on Netflix
it is the film dream killer about a man
imprisoned for murder and exonerated
with the help of attorney Kathleen
Zellner who features in making a
murderer Kathleen does watched it
yesterday in the day before in a couple
uh tranches I guess I would say and
check it out
very very well-done documentary and an
interesting story it would be curious to
hear what people think about it
thanks to Pete crock for the super chat
Maria
areola say oh where did that go what do
you think about the stimulus check will
we have to pay back after taxes next
year no so that's a false rumor so
here's the deal
the way that the stimulus is being done
is when you do your taxes next year you
would report receiving a $1,200
stimulus and then you get a $1,200
credit so it's a wash you have to report
it somehow right if you make 50k but you
got a $1,200 stimulus check that $1,200
has to show up somewhere so it shows up
as a government stimulus check but then
you get a dollar for dollar $1,200
credit so it washes you you made 50k you
got 1,200
you got a $1,200 credit so your taxable
remains at 50k - of course your your
standard deduction or whatever else so
node understanding is that that was
literal fake news that was spreading
Ryan coal tallow says my girlfriend then
I watch your live stream with maniac
bingo everyday exciting new products for
coronavirus customers has become a
staple expression in our household
thanks for the humor yeah yeah I am
constantly using the term elements
around my girlfriend and she sometimes
gets it and sometimes doesn't because
sometimes I slip it in so discreetly
into the conversation and I all I've
been using elements a lot what else have
I been using when talking with family I
will very often refer to the invisible
enemy or the invisible scourge and
actually how do you say scourge in
Spanish translates you Spanish actually
don't know that word doesn't I don't
know if that's right in any case yeah
I'm introducing a lot of that language
myself we have oh dear God who are these
people
is this is this Trump's panel of people
what is going on here this looks very
this looks weaponized I don't know that
I like this but in the meantime let me
thank a few other people Nancy Anderson
is new patron number 22 today Thank You
Nancy
Shaun Clark is new patron number 23
Maggie Dover is new patron number 24
Johanna is new patron number 25 which
makes me say let's go for 50 let's see
if we can do it Susan Kazon ow or case
now is new patron number 26 and with
$100 per month pledge Wow a nunzio tech
ol is new patron number 27 I really
appreciate that so generous contribution
Annunziata I also want to say thanks to
Tiffany daus who is new patron number 28
today at patreon.com slash david pakman
show if you're joining us and once again
wondering what the hell is going on this
was scheduled for 35 minutes ago you're
in the same boat I am I anticipate that
this will be a crazy press conference we
see dr. Burks arriving um
I expect to see Trump do endless
bragging about how great everything he's
done is we might hear a little bit about
Trump's plan to start reopening certain
aspects of the economy he said we would
hear that this week I think today is
gonna be a crazy one I really really do
and if you're just joining us on YouTube
please do me the favor of hitting the
like button and the subscribe button
you really are helping our streams every
time you do it it costs nothing and it's
a beautiful thing we can all do as we
are self isolating today we are not the
scourge we are the the anti scourge is
the way I like to say it
Michael Blanco says there are many anti
VAX Trump supporters do you think if a
vaccine is eventually developed Trump
will sow uncertainty around it to appeal
to them no that's the funny thing when
the rubber meets the road Trump
so Wow dr. Burks right up front there a
Donald Trump sort of uh played nice
coddled the anti-vaccine
but now that we're talking about a
vaccine you don't hear a word from Trump
you don't hear an anti VAX word from
Donald Trump anymore I think Trump won't
and honestly I think most of the
anti-vaxxers are just gonna get the
vaccine what will be fascinating is
after everything with kovat 19 and
eventually when we get a vaccine you're
gonna see tons of people get the Cova
vaccine get the corona virus vaccine and
continue not getting the flu vaccine
with the same bogus arguments that
clearly are bad arguments as proven by
coronavirus there's no question about it
you're going to see it Pitt says hi from
Australia please will someone introduce
some sanity into US politics good luck
it's an uphill battle Allie max says how
screwed is Trump after his presidency
sadly I don't know that there will be
consequences i I don't I wish that there
were but I am NOT confident that that is
going to be the case
ken Heron says if you move your chat
screen to your right it will make it
look as if you are reading them from the
same script screen as we are there are a
lot of really complicated reasons why I
can't do that
let me think let me see if there's some
other way now there would have to be a
lot done there would have to be a lot
done
really let me see let me see I
understand that you know breaking eye
contact with you fine folks is not a oh
no I know why I can't do it there's a
there's a different reason why I can't
do it let me see hmm let me just try
something here my friends if I do this
and then I go to over here
huh and then maybe if I collapse the
chat yeah it's pretty tough to do I'm
gonna need to I that's it that's a
reasonable request that it seems like
I'm looking away from the camera when I
read super chats I am going to work on
that between today and tomorrow okay
point taken
it's almost like turning my back to the
audience which I don't want to do but
I'm just not set up for that right now
okay Eric Swanson says how many times do
you think Trump will mention hydroxi
today isn't he invested in a company
that makes it he has under a thousand
and possibly under $100 worth of one of
the many companies that make it I would
not focus my energy on saying that's why
Trump is promoting it I think there are
other reasons psychological reasons why
Trump is promoting it let me say thank
you to Dana Dana is new patron number 29
today Kim rue or rayou is new patron
number 30 today and Kalyan Webb is new
patron number 31 also want to say thanks
to Damon Watlington whose new patron
number 32 today and mark Bishop Marquez
new patron number 33 let me to see you
can I do some quick math on this 33
divided by 50 okay 3 into 5 1 carry the
zero 33 boom I'm kidding obviously 66%
of the way there and very very much
appreciative okay Connor Brennan Brenner
says how thoughts on IMF outlook I don't
understand how optimistic the domestic
stock market is thoughts on how the
market has been reacting to this crisis
I love this question so last Friday as
an example it was announced that six
point eight six point six more people
lost their jobs the week before and the
stock market went up why did the stock
market go up it doesn't make sense okay
I'm gonna give you an idea here are some
elements of why that's the case
stock markets don't like uncertainty and
price in some of what is expected to
come in the future so the day before 6.6
more million job losses were
bounced some anticipatory pricing of
that announcement was already in the
market in other words the market if you
believe efficient markets hypothesis
which is [ __ ] in 100% but there's a
you know there's an idea of it that
certainly the market anticipates future
news as much as it reflects previous
news the stock market had already sort
of priced in the fact that a lot of
people were losing were losing their
jobs that week when the announcement was
made two things happened that could have
pushed the stock market up other than
just people speculating which of course
is actually a scourge and terrible for
the economy one is it eliminated
uncertainty right for for the week
leading up to Friday there was
uncertainty about how many jobs were
going to be lost we now know or we did
we learned at that time number two that
number was the number of people filing
for unemployment filing for unemployment
means they're going to get the money so
it was also news as much as it is news
about people losing their jobs it's news
about 6.6 million people who are now
going to start getting money which they
can spend in the economy and they will
spend it because they need to spend it
to buy staples and then number three the
number was arguably bad enough that it
made the markets think more stimulus is
coming which will be good for us so you
know I I am NOT a believer in efficient
markets theory to the degree that you
know neoclassical economists are but it
is undeniable that to some degree
markets anticipate future news in their
price level and there were bits of news
in that 6.6 million number that would
suggest that money will be injected into
the economy and that would to some
degree explain that now step back for a
second it's bonkers that headline from
CNBC last week best stock market Week in
history
17 million people have lost their jobs
in three weeks like that's nuts
that's nuts and it shows us how
fundamentally disconnected the Main
Street and Wall Street are in so many
ways
okay I sort of went off on a rant there
and I apologize for that
Courtney Richards says thanks for making
yesterday's briefing bearable thank you
Jr says do you think that people will
adapt if Trump is reelected in November
more depression than anger or the other
way around we people will have to adapt
if Trump gets another four years what
choice is there he will be President and
that will be it
Amy gray what where does that go
Amy gray says Trump's behavior during
yesterday's press briefing was bizarre
since 2016 I've been waiting to wake up
from a crazy dream how did we get to
this point
I asked myself that every day Amy you're
you are not alone in that thinking the
Empress says with what happened
yesterday it's amazing how much we are
living Animal Farm George Orwell was a
prophet I read Animal Farm just two
weeks ago and you are absolutely correct
pear tieran says strange but the super
chat is going in and out of focus that's
really weird and that reminds me I do
want to go we want to go to HD and let's
see none of these other streams are live
yet that's a bad sign I mean at least
dr. Burks is here that suggests it's
going to start soon usually what I do
when these start is I'll switch to
c-span for two reasons number one
c-span's video quality seems to be
better and number two c-span tends to
show video of the reporters asking
questions and that's uh that's not an
that's not a trivial matter for me so
I'll probably switch to c-span when they
get started
Matt Chavez says would love to see you
at these briefings are you able to I
live in Boston nobody's traveling the
White House would never give me a press
pass so I would not hold my breath for
that my friend okay let me say a few
other thank-yous to people that are
contributing today we are asking with
total peace and love if you want to
support these streams make a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
doesn't have to be a big pledge pledge
you don't have to pledge a lot to quote
the president you can pledge a little as
little as $1
Moe Hussein is new patron number 34
today
Kenneth Mobile or Kenneth Mobile is new
patron number 35 today and Kay Sanders
is new patron number 36 Kay very
generously pledging 10 bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I've
received you know there is some part of
all this that's going on that is
definitely bringing people together and
I've received so many nice emails from
people who mostly on the left but some
even on the right who have said it's
just great to check in every day for the
most part I'm taking weekends off and
just watch the stream you know we're all
kind of in this thing together we're all
dealing with Trump's insanity together
we're all just trying to get through
this thing together and have received a
lot of really really nice messages and I
really appreciate that let me say some
at which thank yous puddin has
subscribed with prime and he went to
Jared 23 has subscribed with prime
that's a reference to the Jared Jewelers
commercials right I haven't seen one of
those in a while Adrien benningfield
says oh sorry no Sean T dro says thank
you for all of your hard work you have
truly helped me view politics in a more
sober way you have really helped me view
of ways we can truly win on the Left
thank you
I appreciate that Adrian benningfield
says Trump equals scourge in Spanish and
other languages right
scourge translated to Spanish as Trump
Keeton Klepper says would you endorse my
run for high school class president I'd
need to know your platform I need to
know your platform first if it's bagels
at the school store every day then you
can count on it GC says keep up the good
work our buckle says scourge Cydia a
saute in Espanola tell you this ok love
it you know of a word I really love in
Spanish is the word did he fool eco
which
I used to think translated as Mele but I
think actually translates as brawl and
for whatever reason I find that word
absolutely hilarious
I find Mele in English to be a really
funny word
oh three four you got to be fully got oh
you're absolutely right yeah
The Fool guy in Spanish I just find it
to be such a funny word I don't know why
and my brother my dad told me a story
the other day about such a three foolish
guy that broke out in front of his high
school when he was in high school my
dad's not currently in high school
obviously Randy Davis says keep it up a
Nunzio to Cole says glad to see that
Trump is starting to follow social
distancing during his nightly campaign
rally i watch every night with you thank
you thank you onions yatta doom lore
says you may be able to just laterally
invert the video I appreciate the stream
check out New Zealand response to Corona
if you get a chance New Zealand's
response from what I've read is very
good very very good okay let me say a
few other thank-yous here Timothy
Stanley has made a pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show now this is a
name I know that this is a northern
European name and it's spelled je and s
like if it was gen plural but I know
it's not pronounced gens is it
pronounced yawns yawns Schaefer is that
how J ENS we have a shockingly high
number of people with that name from
some of the northern European countries
and I want to I might as well learn to
pronounce it at this point je
yawns yawns yen's no it's not it yawns
I'm saying it like you know yawn why aw
n just spelling it with a why doesn't
actually tell me how to pronounce it
yen's like the currency that doesn't
sound right
the one with Jen's Jen's is actually how
you pronounce it all right listen III
appreciate the support from Jen's or
yawns or however you pronounce it and I
mean no disrespect
if I'm pronouncing it the wrong way okay
Sharon Mickey has grabbed the YouTube
membership thanks Sharon where'd that go
Seth Barham says many are complaining
about the ih amoeba model being wrong is
it due to the mitigation efforts or is
there evidence to suggest it was bungled
let's pull it up so here's the IH a me
model let's see if it was updated today
it was not so for a while I've been
wondering about some some parts of this
model this is the model that projected
the total number of deaths as well as
the deaths per day the projection was
that the US would peak at about 2600
deaths per day at its biggest projection
that was revised downward and as you can
see here we've seen sort of a leveling
off of the deaths going all the way back
to April 7th the thing that makes me
doubt the model is actually the
Massachusetts numbers and I'm gonna
explain to you why here in Massachusetts
it is projecting 8200 deaths now so far
in Massachusetts we have let me just
refresh this we have nine hundred and
fifty-seven deaths and very often the
model will say you know today you're
expected to have a hundred and twenty
six so on and so on and so forth
typically we've been below it as you can
see the curve was starting here and it
was going to go all the way across and
as you can see we've kind of cut across
that curve quite a bit now maybe it will
end up being right I mean today in
Massachusetts we had 113 deaths I think
this is the worst day we've ever had in
Massachusetts but I mean listen maybe
we're going to have 8200 deaths here it
strikes me as very high given that our
total is still under a thousand I just
don't know you know I I am NOT a modeler
I don't know what's going on in any
state acutely the way I know what's
going on in Massachusetts when I saw
8200 deaths
it seems high to me but when it comes to
the global the national numbers it's not
been terrible I mean it's been there's
there have been some downward
adjustments it's not been terrible we'll
see again this was last updated on April
13 we'll see what it looks like
maybe tomorrow it's going to be updated
I don't know let me say thanks to child
Oh skills for subscribing over on Twitch
very much appreciate that I want to say
thank you to Emily null fo MD thank you
doctor very much appreciate your support
on patreon you are patron number 39
today and Linda Julian is new patron
number 40 today at patreon.com slash
david pakman show so appreciate your
support okay we are now 52 minutes past
when this was supposed to start if we
let me just pull up Trump's Twitter to
see if he has made any pronouncements
about the start time today he said a
5:45 he posted that at 5:20 so 20
minutes after he was supposed to start
he announced that it was going to be at
5:45
that's very soon that's very soon
Townsend Cokie says thoughts on the
Smithfield pork plant outbreak there
seems to be a lot of seating outbreaks
among among food workers yet still no
risk to the food supply chain I don't
know enough to be able to comment about
that but it is very concerning now pork
specifically I don't care about I don't
eat pork but the food supply certainly
is a general topic of concern mr. Sachs
a--quite says nah homie was saying if
your stream window was on the left when
looking to your right it'll seem like
you're reading them off the stream as we
see it no timer effort needed to
allocate towards eye contact also here's
$20 okay thank you Zoey Ferguson says
says is Trump using the Rose Garden to
get out of questions from the press the
press still asked questions in the Rose
Garden and here they have the boom mic
which will be used to ask questions
Anubis Oh Casey says got a job for a 15
year police veteran
we are not hiring right now we're doing
everything we can to avoid having to you
know cut hours or that type of thing and
thankfully we are not needing to do that
thanks to support of people like for
example people pledging on patreon and
that sort of thing but we don't have any
new positions available right now
Sabrina Zafar says enjoyed the market
analysis long-form videos into the
various functions of the economy please
good idea Sabrina I hope you're doing
well Kris call is a new soy boy level
member on YouTube CS Patterson's
Patterson says look at stream yard to
help all streaming I'm not familiar with
that Maddie Ice says are you a fan of
Mike's pastry not really no I mean it's
very very touristy here in Boston and
when I'm in that neighborhood I tend to
go to Cafe Brico not the restaurant but
like the little sandwich shop down the
alley and then sometimes modern pastry
or I'll go over to cafe vitória and get
a macchiato and a cannoli or tiramisu
potentially but no I don't really go to
Mike's off I mean it's just so busy with
tourists but by there's no need
constitutional peasant says should we
shame the leftists who say they won't
vote Biden in the general no listen I'm
taking a much more not it's not that I'm
resigned but I don't want to fight with
people right so like last night on
Twitter there was a big kerfuffle
involving me
Kyle kolinsky and Mehdi Hasan I don't
know how many of you know Mehdi Hasan
and it was very respectful and it's like
listen if you don't want to vote for
Biden don't vote for Biden just
understand that it is an action that
helps Trump not voting is not voting
right so in a literal sense not voting
is not a vote for Trump not voting is
not voting you are getting Trump one
vote closer to re-election in practice
but I don't need to fight with people
matter I don't care
do whatever you want all I can do is
tell you what I'm doing of course I
believe what I'm doing is correct and if
people want to join me then go ahead
people don't we'll have four more years
of Trump and then we'll deal with it the
best we can in the blue states we will
be more isolated we are in a position of
privilege in many blue states where we
are more isolated from the machinations
and and atrocities of Donald Trump
in the red states you'll be more screwed
what can I do right I mean all I can do
is tell you why I'm voting Biden and
it's up to everybody to decide but I am
NOT interested in starting to fight with
people if you're comfortable getting
Trump one vote closer with your action
which is the way I would put it have at
it and then well you know there will be
repercussions I would remind folks many
of the successes for example of the
Progressive Era in the early 1900's were
because of who was on the Supreme Court
many of the successes of the Progressive
Era but could have been struck down were
it not for who was on the court that is
chosen by presidents so I want Biden
replacing whoever it is that may leave
the court in the next four years
I don't want Trump doing it and 15 years
from now that may well pay dividends so
everybody do what they want you know
we're all in this thing together and
we're gonna have to we're gonna be in it
together regardless of who wins I hope
that it's Joe Biden let me say thank you
to Thomas noff who is new patron number
41 today and John Simon is new patron
number 42 thank you so much we are now
up to what is the total number of
patrons we were just at 1803 let me
refresh 1824 beautiful beautiful 1850
would be a nice goal for today why not
right why not if you're just joining us
you have missed nothing we really are
about an hour late today in starting
today's press briefing expecting it's
gonna start getting dark before this
thing ends at this point we have been
expecting Donald Trump for the last hour
he rescheduled two
45 and it is now 15 minutes past that
brutal brutal brutal brutal stuff okay
Leigh Leigh Trias has sent a super chat
Chris K says I keep doing the same thing
every day the press meetings expecting
different results is that insanity no I
think we're all hoping for something
different to happen each day
Abbie Vasquez says if you had White
House credentials what question would
you ask I don't know I mean I'd have to
think about that it depends on the day
Henry Vinson has signed up on YouTube
sage a gaboon bag Boone oh hold on babba
hone there we go you gave a great effort
yesterday though babba hone it's right
there and I was pronouncing it
incorrectly babba hone do you think any
right-wing media outlets will call trump
out for his ignorance of states rights
no not during the press briefing
you know maybe you'll have some
constitutional conservative podcast or
something called Trump out but I I would
be shocked if anybody did that during
the press briefing
'la patriots has subscribed on YouTube
John Simon sends a super chat Don
Sanford has subscribed Emanuel Ramirez
Vera says if Biden loses will Bernie
supporters be blamed I don't have no
idea I'm not I'm not engaging in that
type of stuff right now all I'm doing is
I'm telling people what I'm doing and
why that's it
Oz says when do you think is a realistic
timeline for a California to lift stay
at home thanks for all you do i I have
no independent opinion I defer to the
medical experts my brother lives and
works in California his job is talking
about May 15 right now at minimum so you
know we'll see music 55 says only open
the country when three hundred and
twenty eight point three million
Americans can be tested government needs
to pass them out like yesterday yeah so
there's a few different analyses I don't
have them in front of me so I can't
quickly find them but one analysis
actually I do have one in front of me
this analysis from I believe Morgan
Stanley says that in order to be able to
our wave 1 return to work in early in
mid-june and wave 2 in midsummer you
need a million tested a capacity by May
31 ok another analysis I saw says you
need to be able to test 22 million a day
because that lets you test the whole
country on a rolling basis every 2 weeks
that's a joke I mean this it we're
testing like a hundred and twenty five
thousand a day to go to 22 million its
we might as well we might as well start
testing Martian bacteria if it exists or
something like that it's laughable and
there are analyses that say that's where
we need to be in order to really be able
to safely test isolate contact trace but
get some elements of the economy going
and that that may well be we otherwise
are likely to see at least a second wave
if not a third wave Sam here says Trump
is waiting for the sudafed to kick in
david pakman germany branch office
headquarters says gen jens is an older
german name say like gents okay so it's
jens je NS is Jen's Thank You Bryan
Holaday says I used to think Trump was
in on the joke of him being president
but yesterday makes me think he believes
everything that comes out of it comes
out of his mouth yeah Trump was an
authoritarian nightmare yesterday truly
an authoritarian nightmare ugly I mean
really really ugly stuff yesterday now I
have people saying it's not pronounced
Jen's that it's pronounced yen's
it seems people can't agree how the name
is pronounced yen's and Danish is just
like yen's it's yen's with a why hmm
all right well people don't seem to
agree Kayne Vinson says have past
presidents been this bad with briefing
punctuality I don't actually know the
answer to that we I was not
live-streaming during the Obama
administration much so I don't remember
Jim Hoffman Kerr where'd that go
Jim hovering Kerr says why have you
never donated to a political campaign I
mean I I don't believe my donations
would make a difference and I think I do
far more by having a show I think my net
influence is much bigger and it's always
felt like my effect is
disproportionately higher through my
show than by sending a little bit of
money also quite frankly I think there's
some element where you know you never
know where candidacies are going to go
and it could create problems for me in
some way as a show host to have donated
to someone and I find it cleaner to just
say listen I'm not I'm not sending
anybody money behind the scenes all I'm
doing is telling you what I think on the
show there's no conflict even
hypothetically between what I say and
the money I'm sending to people because
I'm just not sending any money to
politicians
it feels cleaner to me in some way and I
don't know if people in the audience
would agree with that real quick if you
have twenty seconds right now please
take a three-question survey at david
pakman.com slash survey we are trying to
gauge to what degree my audience is
being affected by coronavirus and I
we've put together just a three question
survey that I would love for you to take
at david pakman.com slash survey let me
see I can actually pull it up I'm not
easily able to pull it up right now but
in any case it's literally 20 seconds
it's just three questions david
pakman.com slash survey survey and i am
interested in seeing the results and we
will see them probably by the end of the
week I would say we're looking at that
very very strongly to quote Donald Trump
okay who would bucket Jesus says David
please stop please keep looking
off-screen through he covets okay Dan
samoflange says do you think coastal
state alliances will leverage staying
closed for more relief checks to
individuals somebody asked the reverse
of that question earlier and I don't
know the answer but it is an interesting
it's an interesting one thomas w says
why would Biden install a progressive
judge he put in Scalia and his treatment
of Anita Hill was abysmal
well he didn't select Scalia and as many
of you know it is very difficult to
block a Supreme Court justice
you you know many Republicans take heat
from their constituents for having voted
to approve justices selected by
Democrats and Joe Biden would select
someone who is way better than Trump
again this isn't about would we rather
who Bernie would select or who Biden
would select because Bernie's not going
to be president it will either be Trump
or Biden selecting the next Supreme
Court justice and I want it to be Joe
Biden over Donald Trump it's it's that
simple it's not you know there's no need
to twist oneself into a pretzel to come
up with any of this stuff okay let's see
here
what else did I want to get to
Ross Pagar Iain says imagine working for
a debt collection agency having to call
people for collections when 16 million
just went on unemployment the White
House should put out guidance to stop
these agree 100% joe romeiro says
translation if you have to choose
between two candidates who've been
accused of sexual assault choose the one
with better policies okay there isn't
there's another perspective on that
Tony Romano has grabbed a YouTube
membership Molly Curran says I was
originally not voting in November after
the briefing yesterday I'll be voting
for Biden I hate that I'm doing it but I
have to try and stop Trump we must we
must
Connor Brenner says glad you love the
question about the market appreciate
your view can you expand on view of IMF
outlook specifically i I just
I'm not informed enough on IMF to be
able to intelligently comment so I will
not because I try to avoid commentary on
things that I am NOT read up on let me
say thank you to bear
Walker Bear Walker is new patron number
43 today the best way to support our now
daily multi our streams
and the broadcast show and the YouTube
clips and the podcast and all of that
stuff is to just grab a pledge of as
little as $1 a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show as of right now
[Music]
1824 generous and beautiful people have
done that and I invite you to get us to
50 patrons today patreon.com slash david
pakman show directly supports these
streams I don't call them perfect
streams and I don't call them beautiful
streams I don't do either I've never
pretended that that's the case but they
are streams for sure that I know Eamon
min-ji's says David I am currently
working on editing an animated manga
battle between Joseph R Biden and Corn
Pops circa 1963 I'll post it on the
subreddit with when done that sounds
incredible Eric Rothschild says the
delay in the press conferences obviously
due to the new task force Kushner Ivanka
aligning their talking points to not
contradict Trump maybe I don't know
Christopher Mauro says your vote for
Biden only matters if you live in a
swing state like I do Florida shaves Lee
has subscribed at the soy boy level
music 55 says did you see Mark Cuban
talked running for president I did I
don't know much about it though Nick
Morocco says what do you think of Kyle :
skis take on just not voting and telling
his audience to do the same I'm against
it listen last night I was involved in a
Twitter of Fiasco with Kyle and Mehdi
Hassan today NFL football player Justin
Jackson got in on the action
it's a real [ __ ] show I'm pulling it up
on my phone now um yeah consider looking
at all if you look at my so I'm Deepak
Minh on Twitter in order to see all of
it I think you have to look at my posts
including replies there's like a tab for
with replies and you can follow it all
and I think I made my perspective very
clear last night and
today throughout this conversation okay
Joe Marku says you said a Biden primary
win in general election loss was the
best outcome for the long term
progressive cause did you change your
mind no it's not that I changed my mind
I did a segment where I said if you only
think about the more distant future you
can game out a scenario where Biden
losing in twenty iDEN being the nominee
but losing is the long-term quote best
outcome for progressives I say in that
segment I still think it is morally
dubious to take an action that allows
Trump to be reelected because he is so
weaponized bad so nothing has changed
that was sort of a thought experiment
segment and I think I've been pretty
clear all along that I can't in good
conscience take any action that would
get Trump any closer to re-election
voting for Trump would count not voting
would count writing someone in would
count etc etc Noah Hine Shaw says I was
not going to vote for Biden in November
until Bernie told me to I'll listen to
whatever Bernie tells me to do I hope
that there's Bernie supporters who feel
the same way although I don't know D Ken
says I feel like Biden is more of a
Republican than a Democrat I'm guessing
he will pick a right-wing judge for the
Supreme Court why does it matter if he
picks the next justice no you're
completely wrong so Bernie and Biden
have the same view on the Paris climate
Accords Bernie and Biden have the same
view on $15 an hour minimum wage Bernie
and right etcetera etc Bernie and Biden
both support the green New Deal is a
framework two different degrees
yes Bernie supports it in a more literal
way Biden supports it as a framework we
can go on and on and on prison reform
eat all this different stuff so I think
it is just right it's right to say Biden
is not a progressive he is a center-left
Democrat it is totally wrong to say
Biden is more of a Republican than a
Democrat it's just wrong I'm I won't
participate in it whatsoever let me say
a few other thank-yous Paul Delaney is
new paid
trend number 44 today at join pakman.com
Paul I'm sorry at patreon.com slash
david pakman show thank you Paul
Jeremy show or shoke Jeremy shock is new
patron number 45
Daniel Perea is new patron number 46
Jacob to astok is new patron number 47
jessica is new patron number 48 Gregory
Smith is new patron number 49 sue
Johnson is new patron number 50 let's go
for 75 and see if we can do it and
Stacie biklen is new patron number 51
today at patreon.com slash david pakman
show why have I been talking about
patreon the last few streams instead of
membership just for kicks we're doing
this every day figure we'll do something
a little bit different Trump is now 75
minutes late to his own press conference
75 minutes late this is disgusting
there's no other word for it and we
don't know what is going on what time is
sunset in DC today sunset Washington DC
7:45 oh okay so it's quite late there
that's interesting actually what time is
sunset in Boston today sunset in Boston
725 oh so they've got 20 extra minutes
of sunlight from the standpoint of
comparing it to Boston but this this
actually is insane at this point 75
minutes late on the press briefing some
random guy says have you read the study
from University of Sydney saying that
Cova deaths are poorly predicted by the
IH ME model please google it Sydney edu
AI F not seen that but I'm going to look
it up i h m e i okay here it is let's
take a look at it just while we are
waiting okay
us death rates inconsistent with IH ME
predictions that okay very good
group of data scientists led by the
University of Sydney's Center for
translational data as science has found
that over 70% of US states had death
rates inconsistent with the IH ME
predictions published on pre-publication
the researchers found the model
substantially underestimates the
uncertainty associated with deaths
seventy percent of US states had a death
rate outside the 95 percent prediction
interval for that state casting doubt on
whether the model is suitable to inform
kovat 19 resource allocation there you
have it so certainly my instinct about
that seem to be correct
here is Trump coming out let's see if we
have the c-span feed that seems to be my
preferred one we don't seem to have it
so we will stick here for airlines all
of our great airlines to participate in
a payroll support program the agreement
will fully support airline industry
workers preserve the vital role airlines
play in our economy and protect
taxpayers our airlines are now in good
shape and they will get over a very
tough period of time that was not caused
by them the United States is continuing
to make substantial progress in our war
against the virus we grieve it every
precious life that has been lost to the
invisible enemy but through the darkness
we can see the rays of light we see that
tunnel and at the end of that tunnel we
see light we're starting to see it more
than ever before we've held our okay I
am going to switch now just because it's
like a full Fox we grieve it every
precious life that has been lost to the
invisible enemy but through the darkness
we can see the rays of light we see that
tunnel and at the end of that tunnel we
see light we're starting to see it more
than ever before we've held
rate the numbers everything we've done
we've been very very strong on it and
very powerful on it
you look at what's happening in other
countries Spain Italy United Kingdom
we're working with them we're trying to
help them especially with ventilators
they've been calling a lot they need
ventilators so badly 15% of counties
within the United States have zero cases
and many counties within the United
States have a very small number of cases
large sections of our country are really
looking at other sections and saying wow
that looks bad but they don't have the
problem I salute the American people for
following our guidelines so in social
distancing even you people is so
different looking out there when I look
at you their devotion your devotion is
saving lives today I'm instructing my
administration to halt funding of the
World Health Organization while a review
is conducted to assess what in a World
Health Organization's role and severely
mismanaging and covering odd the spread
of the middle pandemic virus everybody
knows what's going on there American
taxpayers provide between 400 million
and 500 million dollars per year to the
w-h-o in contrast China contributes
roughly 40 million dollars a year and
even less as the organization's leading
sponsor the United States has a duty to
insist on full accountability you're one
of the most dangerous and costly
decisions so if the question is how is
Trump keeping Americans safe from the
virus this is not helping to travel
restrictions from China and other
nations they were very much opposed to
what we did fortunately I was not
convinced and suspended travel from
China saving untold numbers of lives
thousands and thousands of people would
have died had other nations likewise
suspended travel from China countless
more lives would have been saved instead
look at the rest of the world look at
parts of Europe
seven nations and regions who follow
w-h-o guidelines and kept their borders
open to China accelerated the pandemic
all around the world many countries said
we're gonna listen to the w-h-o and they
have problems the likes of which they
cannot believe nobody can believe the
decision of other major countries to
keep travel open was one of the great
tragedies and missed opportunities from
the early days the WHS attack on travel
restrictions put political correctness
above life-saving odd travel ban the
middle of a pandemic he's talking about
political correctness that quarantine
work pandemics depend on human to human
transmission border control is
fundamental to virus control since its
establishment in 1948 the American
people have generously supported the
World Health Organization to provide
better health outcomes for the world and
most importantly to help prevent global
health crises with the outbreak of the
kovat 19 pandemic we have deep concerns
whether America's generosity has been
put to the best use possible the reality
is that the w-h-o fail to adequately
obtain vet and share information is a
genuine transparent fashion the world
depends on the w-h-o to work with
countries to ensure that accurate
information about international health
threats is shared in a timely manner and
if it's not to independently tell the
world the truth about what is happening
the w-h-o failed in this basic duty and
must be held accountable it's time after
all of these decades the w-h-o failed to
investigate credible reports from
sources in Wuhan that conflicted
directly with the Chinese government's
official accounts there was credible
information to suspect human to human
transmission
in December 2019 which should have
spurred the w-h-o to investigate and
investigate a me so he's admitting that
it dates back to December all right
about something it paired it and
publicly endorsed the idea that there
was not human to human transmission
happening despite reports and clear
evidence to the contrary the delays the
w-h-o experience in declaring a public
health emergency cost valuable time
tremendous amounts of time more time was
lost in the delay it took to get a team
of international experts into right so
that delay cost time lie and lives his
delay wouldn't have made any difference
though that's what we're supposed to
believe here WH o to obtain virus
samples to this date has deprived the
scientific community of essential data
new data that emerges across the world
on a daily basis points to the
unreliability of the initial reports and
the world received all sorts of false
information about transmission and
mortality The Silence of the w-h-o on
the disappearance of scientific
researchers and doctors and our new
restrictions on the sharing of research
into the origins of kovat 19 in the
country of origin is deeply concerning
especially when we put up by far the
largest amount of money not even close
had the w-h-o done its job to get
medical experts into china to
objectively assess the situation on the
ground and to call out china's lack of
transparency the outbreak could have
been contained at a source with very
little death very little death and
certainly very little death by
comparison if the same would have saved
thousands of lives and avoided worldwide
economic damage instead the w-h-o
willingly took china's assurances to
face value and they took it just at face
value and defended the actions of the
Chinese government even praising China
for its so-called transparency I don't
think so
the WHL pushed China's misinformation
about the virus saying it was not
communicable and there was no need for
travel bans they told us when we put on
our travel ban a very strong travel band
well there was no need to do it don't do
it they actually fought us the wh o--'s
reliance on China's disclosures likely
caused a 20-fold increase in cases
worldwide and it may be much more than
that
the WHL has not addressed a single one
of these concerns nor provided a serious
explanation that acknowledges its own
mistakes of which there were many
America in the world have chosen to rely
on the w-h-o for a so I think we get it
it's an anti w-h-o rant so
yesterday's press briefing was playing a
propaganda video attacking most of the
journalists in the room is fake but not
all and denying all responsibility while
claiming he has absolute authority in a
dictatorial fashion today it's about
attacking the w-h-o note that none of
this stuff helps get beyond this none of
this saves lives none of this helps
anybody its weaponized delusions of
grandeur and narcissism Earl
tremendous death and economic
devastation because those tasked with
protecting us by being truthful and
transparent failed to do so
it would have been so easy to be
truthful and so much death has been
caused by their mistakes we will
continue to engage with the w-h-o to see
if it can make meaningful reforms for
the time being we will redirect global
health and directly work with others all
of the aid that we send will be
discussed at very very powerful little
letters and and with very powerful and
affluent Yogi's and smugglers medically
politically in every other way it will
be dead we'll be discussing it with
other countries and global health
partners what we do with all of that
money that goes to w-h-o and maybe w-h-o
will reform and maybe they won't but
we'll be able to see as you know in
other countries hit hard by the virus
hospitals have been tragically forced to
ration medical care and the use of
ventilators but due to our early and
aggressive action the skill of our
healthcare workers and the resilience of
our healthcare system no hospital in
America has been forced to deny any
patient access to a ventilator with all
of the talk you've heard where some
states wanted 40,000 ventilators I said
that doesn't work 40,000 and they ended
up with seven or eight thousand and they
had no problem 40,000 ventilators for
one state was ridiculous the scariest
day of my life was about a month ago
when after a long day of meetings my
team told me that we were going to be
needing 130,000 ventilators
that we were short hundreds of thousands
of ventilators he's confused by the
notes he was positively slowed today I
had governor's requesting unreasonable
sums that the federal government just
didn't have and you look at the states
the states didn't have the states were
not prepared I knew that every person
who needed a ventilator and didn't get
one would die and that's what we were
told they would die I saw in other
countries doctors having to make
decisions on who got a ventilator and
who didn't he already said that and I
knew that this would be a defining
challenge of the crisis those that
didn't get ventilators were said to be
in a position only of one alternative
and that was death guys he's repeating
the same thing he's really be able to
prevent Americans from dying because we
couldn't get them ventilators and the
ventilators that they needed and they
need it immediately I instructed my team
to move heaven and earth to make sure
that this didn't happen we started to
smartly ration and distribute the
ventilators that we had and that others
had and I got daily updates on the
supply we had from requests coming in
and people wanting to have updates we
had a great group of people working on
it I instructed my team to use the
defense protection act and the defense
production act was used very powerfully
more powerfully than anybody with
defence protection or defense production
that for the most part we didn't have to
officially take it out it was a hammer
it was a very powerful hammer in order
to manufacture as many ventilators as
possible last year America manufactured
from a dead start 30,000 ventilators and
this year the number will be over a
hundred and fifty thousand ventilators
it could be as high as 200 thousand far
more than we'll ever need
so we'll be able to stockpile we'll be
able to talk to States about stockpiling
these are high quality ventilators we
had a choice we could do inexpensive
less productive ventilators or high
quality we've done a high quality
ventilator so we should have anywhere
from 150 to 200 thousand ventilators in
addition to that we have 10,000
ventilators right now in the federal
stockpile ready to move should we need
them we might not should we need the
last week he said it was 8,000 do they
get 2,000 more or what happened we just
don't know is it a lie is that the truth
it's it's chaos we don't know or any
other state that may need them if we
have a surge I'd like to ask Adam bowler
to come up and just say a few words he's
done a fantastic job young man who
worked 24 hours a day on handling this
situation and I just like to have have
Adam wherever he may be come up and say
a few words Adam please thank you very
much I am seeing the patreon pledges for
people asking that the thing will keep
ticking up thank you
Thank You mr. president at your
direction this country has worked hard
over the past few weeks to ramp up
ventilator production through all means
possible
thousands of ventilators are coming in
now monthly with over a hundred thousand
by the end of June at the same time
there are over 60,000 ventilators and
our hospitals right now that are not in
use knowing this and at your direction
we reached out to the American Hospital
Association to design a system that
allows hospitals to lend ventilators to
other hospitals right when they need it
within the past week alone 20 top health
systems have signed up for this dynamic
ventilator reserve representing over
4,000 ventilators not only do we have
top academic systems like Cleveland
Clinic and Mayo Clinic but we also have
top health systems from New York City
New Orleans Washington State and
California over a week ago these places
would have needed help but now they are
here too
there's been no American that is needed
a ventilator that has not received one
this dynamic virtual reserve combined
with our strategic stockpile will ensure
that this is always the case I'd like to
thank the president for his leadership
and directive to focus on public-private
partnerships like this one I'd also like
to thank Sam Hazen from HCA Lloyd Dean
from common spirit big money bleeding
the cells with OJ and the Federation of
American hospitals these have been
difficult times a few weeks ago
the Vice President came in in my office
and he run reminded us of the power of
the resilience of the American people
and a private companies we needed it
that day mr. vice president
yeah this partnership is another example
of Americans helping America meaningless
brown-nosing q thank you sir Wow I'd
shake his hand but I'm not allowed to
times have changed I was awkward thank
you very much you did a fantastic job
we're very proud of you you and your
whole team thank you today we are taking
further action to maximize our
oversupply and available ventilators
this afternoon I met with the leaders
the top people of many of America's big
powerful beautiful and you know very
very important hospitals and hospital
associations who join us today I mean a
great meeting learned a lot and they've
been going through a lot they've been
doing a fantastic job as everybody here
will attest I'm pleased to announce that
my administration is partnering with the
hospitals across the country to create
an innovative new system called the
dynamic ventilator reserve so the
tremendous numbers of ventilators that
were able to help our state's with at a
later date if there's ever a problem
like this which we hope to God will
never happen again
1917 1918
that's a long time ago we hope it never
happens again and I'd like to ask Rick
[ __ ] a CEO of American Hospital
Association Sam Hayes and CEO of HCA
healthcare that's the largest in the
United States I'd love to bring up
people profiting heavily from the virus
folks come on up and tell me how great
I'm doing and if I could my Hall you are
you here from Cleveland Clinic somebody
good thank you come on up folks please
thank you say a few words that a hand
very much mr. president
and I appreciate the opportunity to work
with you and your team to make a ton of
this later Reserve Program this will
provide a really important mechanism for
us in serving our patients and
communities by ensuring that this vital
equipment will be available to critical
areas that are in need you know as this
battle against this disease has affected
the country a little bit unevenly the
rates of infection hospitalization in
ICU use varies from one region to
another in some places with lower
infection rates some ventilators may not
be in use while other areas are
potentially stretched beyond their
capacity the database of available
ventilators that we are creating will
allow us to flex and so that we can make
sure that available equipment can be
shared with those in need we appreciate
the leadership of the health systems
that are here today that has stepped
forward and Adam mentioned a few I don't
know if he caught dr. Fritz Francois
from NYU Langone and David ill the CEO
of Life point as well we appreciate the
work of the administration in helping us
find innovative solutions to ensure the
best care for our patients we'll
continue to work with hospitals and
health systems across the country is a
Boston dad to this reserve further your
teammates provided us with important
leadership and we look forward to
working with you and making this a
success thank you mr. president
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president
Adam the team I stand here before you
you in front of our 285,000 colleagues
who provide care to patients every day
across the country one of the guiding
principles we had when we went into this
Cove at nineteen battle was to find
partnerships partnerships with other
components of the industry partnerships
with other health systems but
partnerships with governments both local
and federal and we're proud to be a part
of this private public sector
partnership and I think it's going to do
great good for the community so thank
you very much thank you it's great to
have action or health be part of this
program we certainly have been a a
recipient and the state of Louisiana has
been a recipient of help getting
ventilators to our state and to
auktioner health we're currently taking
care of about 60% of the kovat patients
in New Orleans and we did see a spike
over the past few weeks but we're
starting to get on the other side of
that and heading in the right direction
I also want to thank you personally for
helping auktioner health a couple weeks
ago we're running short on surgical
gowns and you and your team were able to
direct some to New Orleans which was
helpful to us and other hospitals around
the New Orleans area so we're excited to
be part of this dynamic ventilator
Reserve and we are proud to be part of
that and help other communities around
the country thank you dynamic ventilator
reserve sounds like consultants have
grabbed for the invitation here on
behalf of the Cleveland Clinic I would
just like to offer a slightly different
story about akavit pandemic in our home
state of Ohio with an early institution
of social distancing our ability to
scale up the testing and ramping out the
capacity we have actually seen a stable
number of patients over the last eight
to ten days only hundred and sixty
patients have been hospitalized with
kovat infection in Cleveland Clinic
Health System we are also very grateful
for the support from our state
government as well from our federal
government this is a battle where we're
all in together
we coordinate our efforts share our
resources and work together as one I'm
firmly convinced that we can do a lot of
good when we work together thank you
very much for having us thank you
beautiful
it was a terrific meeting and thank you
all for being here thank you very much
the United States has far more ICU beds
per capita than any other nation we have
34.7 ICU beds per 100,000 people that's
true which is the best there is
compared with roughly 12.5 beds per
100,000 in Italy 11.6 beds in France 9.7
beds in Germany 34.7 we have and 6.6 in
the UK there are more than 60,000
ventilators at hospitals and other
health care facilities that are not in
use at this moment they didn't need them
we got a lot of them out and they didn't
need them and that's a good thing that
they didn't need him but a lot of good
brainpower was involved in making a lot
of fantastic decisions I want to thank
our vice president for the task force
and I want to thank all members of your
Task Force on having done an incredible
job you really have done an incredible
job thank you Mike very much through
this new partnership with the hospitals
unused ventilators will voluntarily lend
them where they have unused ventilators
they will voluntary lend those ventless
to other hospitals and other areas of
greater need within the last several
days more than 20 of our nation's
largest health systems have already
pledged more than four thousand
ventilators should we need them and I've
been told that understand that the
ventilator topic is just not the primary
topic right now and we're you know what
20 minutes in and it's all he's talked
about other than cutting funding to the
w-h-o so it started but we'll really
start about less than a month we're
going to be helping other countries and
they need
very badly they have no chance without
these ventilators they have to have
ventilators as we continue our medical
war against the virus the FDA has now
authorized the first test developed by
researchers from Rutgers University that
can use saliva from patients first one
these tests can be self administered by
patients and healthcare settings which
will reduce exposure for medical workers
and save personal protective equipment
Rutgers will begin processing ten
thousand tests daily so by using saliva
that's the first they'll be able to do
things in terms of speed and ease that
we haven't been able to do before so a
lot of great innovation is taking place
during this period of time and that's
innovation I call it innovation under
pressure it's a big difference
innovation under pressure right right
Cleveland Clinic knows all about that as
we prepare for the next phase of this
great struggle we must also do
everything in our power to restore
prosperity for the American worker
there's tremendous interest and
excitement surrounding the
administration's efforts to get the
economy roaring once again and I think
it's going to roar once it gets open I
think it's going to go up tremendously
you see what's happening with the stock
market already because a lot of really
smart financial people the great minds
they're looking at the stock and they're
saying well because they really what
they're really seeing is how we're doing
if we weren't doing well the market
wouldn't be at a level that it is today
he doesn't understand the market they
have a lot of confidence that we're
doing the right thing and that our
country is going to be open soon and our
country is going to be booming they who
we've had requests to participate from
the best in the world as we share their
enthusiasm to get our country going so I
thank them for wanting to contribute and
we look forward to speaking with many
industry leaders seeking their input on
how we can return to what was until very
recently the greatest economy anywhere
in the world in
I can say the greatest economy in the
history of the world has never been an
economy like we had just a little bit
more than a month ago we said every
record you could said more people
working than we've ever had working
before almost 160 million just 9 we're
also more people not working because the
population keeps getting bigger you have
more people working and more people not
working at most points nobody was doing
well stock market at a record 142 days
that hit a record and I think we're
going to top those records ok and I
think we're going to top them soon once
we get rid of the invisible enemy which
will happen the plans to reopen the
country are close to being finalized and
we will soon be sharing details and new
guidelines with everybody I will be
speaking to all 50 governors very
shortly and I will then be authorizing
each individual governor authorizing of
each individual state to implement a
reopening and a very powerful reopening
plan governors are going to do what they
want at a time and in a manner as most
appropriate the day will be very close
because certain states as you know are
in much different condition and in a
much different place than other states
it's going to be very very close maybe
even before the date of May first so
that will be for some states actually
there are over 20 that are in extremely
good show and be able to get them open
fairly quickly and then others will
follow the federal government will be
watching them very closely and will be
there to help will be there to help in
many different ways as we've been where
we built hospital beds at a number that
nobody's ever seen before where we did
the ventilators that we just discussed
at a level that nobody's ever seen
before nobody can even believe other
foreign countries
even powerful countries can't believe
what we were able to do with ventless be
our focus big producing countries can't
believe what we were able to do we will
hold the governor's accountable
oh but again we're going to be working
with them to make sure it works really
well now we have a list of people that
I'll be speaking to over the next very
short period of time in many cases
tomorrow we're going to have elected
officials and we'll be submitting that
list to you within the next 24 hours but
we have a list of different industries a
point that I'll be discussing by meeting
by telephone because we don't want
people traveling right now the American
Farm Bureau Federation zippy Duvall
Cisco Systems Tyson Foods Perdue farms
Cargill Archer Daniels Midland Court Eva
tractor supply company right seaboard
corporation Grimm way farms Mount Ayr
farms and others in the agricultural
business and banking it's Bank of
America Brian Moynihan has been great JP
Morgan Chase Jamie Dimon guy Goldman
Sachs it's it's a satire it's be a Wells
Fargo US Bancorp Morgan Stanley James
Gorman Grand Rapids State Bank Southern
Bank Corp all great institutions with
lots to say and lots of good ideas and
Wow you look at how paycheck has been
working out the numbers are incredible
and I hope Congress is going to be able
to supplement the amount of money going
to our workers I hope they're able to
get that done very quickly because it's
been an incredible success and many are
already spending that money and the
money's been distributed at numbers that
nobody believed possible for this short
period of time was only a week ago but a
lot of money has been distributed
already it's going to keep our small
businesses open
the construction labor workforce
International Union of Operating
Engineers Jim Callahan North America
Building Trades Union Shaun McGarvey is
there a lot of friends of mine in this
is of no value just submit the list
later it says nobody knows most of these
people's names it's clear it's just his
friends she ation David long Bechtel
floor National Association of Home
Builders Association of builders and
contractors associated general
contractor's Richard Trumka AF of l-cio
G H Palmer so these are some of the
union's pretty much almost all of the
ones that will be on the line right in
defense we have Lockheed Martin
Honeywell Northrop Grumman Korres are
all the top of each company CEOs
Chairman's presidents Raytheon General
Dynamics Energy weekend it finished
tremendous credit going to Russia and
Saudi Arabia and it catches 20 million
barrels a day a cut so we can get rid of
some of the tremendous yes at an email
it's me oil that's been produced because
of the fact that the virus just knocked
out almost 50% of the business it's been
an amazing achievement
some people say one of the biggest oil
deals ever made maybe the biggest oil
deal ever made they're saying I didn't
know that but we were involved in
getting that done and it was very
important we're gonna save hundreds of
thousands of jobs for meaningless drivel
energy industry Texas and North Dakota
Oklahoma all of our different energy
states it's great so we're very happy
about it I want to thank everybody we
had the it's called OPEC plus that's
OPEC plus very good super catchy
Commission's outside of our neck and I
also want to thank the President of
Mexico because he was he was terrific
you overdo what dexterity and
flexibility and
getting the deal done we want to thank
him very much on the energy front we had
Exxon Mobil Continental Resources
Chevron Southern Company Alabama Power
ConocoPhillips Occidental Petroleum kind
of Morgan Hess corporation Perot group
and few others big ones great ones yep
financial services we have Blackstone
Stephen Schwarzman Paulson and company
John Paulson
so Mike Cameron Elliott Management Paul
singer Vista Equity Partners Robert
Smith fidelity investments Abigail
Johnson MasterCard Visa chub chubs oh
yeah there's a net job Stevens Warren
Stevens great Charles Schwab Chuck
Schwab
will be here by phone food and beverage
National Restaurant Association
McDonald's Darden Restaurants coca-cola
pepsi-cola chick-fil-a subway bloomin
brands Yum Brands Papa John's Wendy's
Waffle House Starbucks Wolfgang Puck
this is insane Thomas Keller is young
George my friend John George someone do
me a favor after this is done without my
voice over it take every company Trump
has named and it's got to be about a
hundred edit it together at like 2 or
2.5 x speed whatever's funniest and
please send it to me we will thank you
and put it on our Twitter I think it
would be funny
worldwide Crowley maritime credible big
powerful still shippers and
transportation companies in
telecommunications we have the legendary
John Malone of Liberty Media Verizon
t-mobile charter communications how is
this little Brian Roberts of Comcast
thank you all very much
I thought yes I care easiest one New
York Presbyterian Gerry spire friend of
mine HCA healthcare Sam
J'son thank you Sam just met with Sam
ascension health common spirit health
community health systems Trinity Health
Cardinal health my Kissin 3m thank you
Mike Roman for helping us with face
masks that worked out well for everybody
Procter and Gamble Abbott Laboratories
Johnson and Johnson Hotel and all that
Merck Pfizer Eli Lilly
Thermo Fisher Scientific they've been
helping us incredibly with testing
Gilead Sciences Abbey vie Regeneron
Biogen Roche and Roche has been
fantastic on testing the job they've
done I have to call them out they have
really it's called a stepped-up now I
call them our he always gets that can
Anthem United Health Group at Cigna and
Humana all the big ones the tech
companies we have the right ones Apple
we have Tim Cook Google in Apple sundar
Thank You sundar Oracle Larry Ellison
Safra Catz Salesforce mark better not
we've already forgotten what will these
companies be doing just profiting from
the virus helping him to reopen what are
they doing
Saachi a great job he's done Thank You
Sergio Facebook Mark Zuckerberg IBM
Intel Qualcomm Cisco ale calm Advanced
Micro Devices that can't be real
Broadcom incredible companies companies
that no other country will catch if
they're smart they have to be smart but
I've dealt with a lot of different
countries and I will say that no the
response of Silicon Valley in our tech
companies there's nobody even close to
our tech companies they can't catch them
so they try and buy them but we sort of
put an end to a lot of that in sports we
want to get our sports back so
importantly these will be some separate
calls we're gonna do that some will be
together by the way list and some will
be set
but we have to get our sports back I'm
tired of watching baseball games at a 14
years old he doesn't want I haven't
actually had too much time to watch I
would say maybe I watch one batter and
then I get back to work
the NBA Adam Silver the major league
baseball we miss our base whether this
is baseball season right here Rob
Manfred thank you very much and as well
Robbie I'm gonna take the opportunity to
say people who are actually making a
difference and just grabbed patreon
pledges but Dan Brown is new patron
number 55 Monica Staggs is new patron
number 56 and Antoinette Rosenman is new
patron number 57 at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show
thanks you guys are doing much much more
than just reading companies which makes
no sense whatsoever
NHL Gary Bettman from the New England
Patriots Bob Kraft Dallas Cowboys Jerry
Jones Dallas Mavericks Mark Cuban and
some of the thought leaders that we're
going to have and there are some others
that we are having with just waiting to
hear but everybody's saying yes I must
say it's like John Ellison Heritage
Foundation cake called James great
person Oh Hoover Institute Condoleezza
Rice another great person art Laffer
Steve more oxygen for Lindsay Catherine
Reynolds Scott Gottlieb just spoke with
Scott Jim DeMint oh boy and Jim has been
that's trouble terrific friend bill
Haggerty and Ray Washburn and religious
leaders will be held no coming don't say
Franklin on Friday we'll be speaking to
you know what we're gonna have a
separate list but we know Frank
tremendous enthusiasm to meet by our
know Jerry for religious leaders we have
incredible people and they want to they
want to be a part and we'll be talking
about churches and we'll be talking
about opening and we'll be talking about
things that are very important to a lot
of people the Easter Bunny ie
we're gonna find out
how we're doing in that regard so those
are the names that we have on our lists
they're the names that are I think the
best and the smartest the brightest does
this have to do with the values of some
ideas but we're all set as I said the
governors are going to be opening up
their states they're going to declare
when they're going to know when some can
open very very shortly if not almost
immediately we'll give a date but the
dates going to be in the very near
future so we'll get it open individual
states when the governors will be held
accountable if they need things we'll
help them get those things but we want
them to do their testing we want them
because they're equipped to do testing
we've created incredible tests and we've
done more testing than anybody's ever
done in the world right now not per
capita we had a broken system and now we
have a great system we have a system
where other countries are coming to us
and saying we want to get some of those
tests that's not true I want to thank
Abbott because Abbott came up with the
first simpler test the first one was
rough if you were I think it's more of
an operation than a test the first one
was for anybody that took it it was not
easy but now we have a very simple to
score super high on we have saliva we
have lots of other things that are
happening but we have millions of tests
the governors are responsible they have
to take charge they have to do a great
job and we're going to suggest that they
check people through tests or otherwise
coming into their states and they run
their States very strong eventually we
won't have to do that eventually this
will be gone but for a while we're going
to do it so they're gonna take charge at
their borders they're gonna take charge
of people coming in and maybe to an
extent depending on what they work out
with a nearby state it may be also
people leaving
yeah I'm sure Andrew Cuomo is just gonna
do exactly what Trump says right we will
be announcing a date but it'll be very
short and frankly it'll be at a time
that will be earlier than the deadline
that we opposed the end of April so we
think that some of the governor's will
be in
really good shape to open up even sooner
than that we'll speak to them but we're
all set we're counting on the governor's
to do a great job all set guys
others are gonna have to take a longer
period of time until they're in a
position to say we're ready to go and
that's okay we understand that some of
the governors have a very tough
situation but in almost all cases it's
all starting to come down we're very
proud of the job everybody's done and if
you look at the numbers so the minimum
as you as portrayed deborah's here
dr. Brooks has been fantastic the
minimum was a hundred thousand deaths
without you and I hope to be
substantially under the minimum meaning
we all hope Mike right we all hope to be
substantially under we did the right
thing because otherwise it would have
been the projections are two million
people the actual projection was 2.2
million people and if you cut it in half
that would be 1.1 million people that's
many more that's double the civil war
remember that's if you do nothing but no
president would be allowed to do nothing
doing nothing shouldn't be the standard
we compare to be cutting it cutting it
and we're not gonna that would not be
acceptable it would not be acceptable
nothing say one life isn't acceptable
but we weren't given that option so I'm
confident that these respected people
that I just read from the list will give
us some great ideas in addition to what
the governors have learned the governors
have learned a lot I've spoken to
governor's that at the beginning it was
a contentious relationship and now it's
a very friendly relationship
relationship and I'm proud to say that
some of them I think are friends in some
cases they're Democrats but I think they
like me and I actually like them I'll
tell you who they are someday but we're
all getting along and we all want to do
the right thing and I think they're
gonna do a great job of leading their
individual states it'll be a beautiful
thing to watch they'll go and rely on
their mayors and their local town
officials they bring it right down and
Washington shouldn't be doing that we
can
be thinking about a Walmart parking lot
that's 2,000 miles away well we're doing
testing but a governor of a state can an
American and write down on the line so
it's gonna be I think it's gonna be a
terrific system and if we're unhappy
with the state we're going to let them
know we're and happy and if they're not
doing the job and they can't get the job
done and for some reason things are
happening that we're not gonna like like
the numbers are heading in a wrong
direction
we'll have to do something that's very
very serious we'll have to maybe close
them up and start all over again but I
don't think we're gonna have to do that
I think the Constitution does not
enumerate any of this as a power of the
President and the governor's will be
making their decisions if someone can
come out very very shortly and we look
forward to watching that process I think
it's gonna be a very beautiful process
our discussions will focus with the
people that we're dealing with on
rejuvenating the economy and always
health always health health and life
living is number one but the rejuvenated
economy and I think it's going to go
quickly will be utilizing our robust
testing capacity for the governor's will
be giving them what they need if they
don't have it themselves we hope by now
they'll be able to have it themselves we
were hoping they would have had it
themselves early on but they weren't but
such great advances have been made so
we'll be dealing with them on that and
we they can rely on us very strongly
they're going to be relying on us I
think for some help and we're there
whether it's building hospital beds
which I don't think they're going to
need you look at Javits Center a great
great job that the Army Corps of
Engineers did FEMA got involved we
actually ended up sending our medical
people that was not a kovat 19 Center
and they asked could you do that and
then even after we did that it was not
used very much meaning they didn't have
to use it nearly to the extent that they
thought when they conceived it it wasn't
that they made a mistake nobody made a
mistake we built it I'd rather have too
much than too little err on the side of
caution and
it's really incredible what they did
including the two ships to two great
ships and I just want to thank a lot of
really great people a lot of great
politicians and again we're going to be
announcing the political list tomorrow
and on there we're going to have a lot
of senators and we're going to be having
a meeting with the governors violently
on Thursday a meeting by teleconference
and a lot of things will be discussed
and some of the details will be in
discussed but we want them to do an
incredible job of running this state's I
think they'll do an incredible job too
after having gotten to know so many of
them I think each one of them will do an
incredible job and again the federal
government is there we have ventilators
if they need them we have beds if they
need a way of hospitals if they need
them we have a testing capacity that's
now second to none where again other
countries are calling us countries that
you thought were doing well are calling
us for his callin testing so we're there
to help Korea and with that if you have
a few questions we'll take them and if
not that would be okay too yeah go ahead
please show mr. president two questions
first on your
Joe Cool's smarter stand to your
grievances with them can you address why
it is the correct time to do this now
well we're going to be dealing with
countries and we're going to be dealing
with leaders of different parts of the
world we spend 500 million a year we
have for many years more far more than
anybody else including China and I mean
look I read off a long list of problems
that we have and we've had problems with
them for years
it doesn't matter we're looking at a
term of 60 to 90 days we're doing a very
thorough investigation right now as we
speak but this should have been done by
previous administrations a long time ago
and when you look at the mistakes that
were made all of the mistakes that were
made it's just something we have to look
at and it is very China centric I told
that to President Xi I said the World
Health Organization is very china
centric meaning whatever it is China was
always right you can't do that can't do
that not right and we spend it again
it's not a question of money
but when we're spending five hundred
million dollars and China is spending
thirty eight million 34 million 40
million 42 million in a case it's again
not money but it's not right so we'll
see this is an evaluation period but in
the meantime we're putting a hold on all
funds going to world health we will be
able to take that money and channel it
to the areas that most needed and that's
another way of doing it but we have not
been treated properly
that you're going to be speaking with
the all the governor's yes make
recommendations on probably Thursday
Thursday what if they don't listen to
you
or take your advice or obey you will you
will you consider taking away their
federal funding I don't want to say that
they'll listen
they'll be fine I think we're going to
have a good relationship they need the
federal government not only for funding
and I'm not saying take it away but they
need it for advice they'll need maybe
equipment that we have we have a
tremendous stockpile that were in the
process of completing we're in a very
good position again the cupboard was
bare when I got here empty I never
thought a thing in all fairness I'd know
Wes administration's nobody ever thought
anything like this was going to happen
but it did happen now the governor's
will be very very respectful of the
presidency again this isn't me this is
the presidency the presidency has such a
greater well no other president would
act in terms of what we're doing and you
could talk about Constitution you can
talk about federalism you can talk about
whatever you want but remember
federalism means that any power not
enumerated in the Constitution for the
federal government in terms of power
over the states rests with the states
Trump has no power in the sense over the
states you talk about having testing and
tracing equipment the
and the facility for that in place to
open up the government doctor found she
said this morning that that critical
testing and tracing ability does not
currently exist
my question is milkiness my question is
will it exists by May 1st the individual
governors have testing the individual
governor's we have many forms of testing
and new testing is being developed our
country has to get open our testing
capacity right now is about a hundred
and twenty-five K a day by conservative
estimates we need a million a day to
start reopening one estimate says we
need twenty two million tests a day to
really open safely governor's will use
whatever testing is necessary and if
they're not satisfied with their testing
they shouldn't open but they'll use
whatever's tested whatever testing is
necessary go ahead Thank You mr.
president back to the WH o will you
support the organization again if Ted
Rios is immediately replaced or do you
want to see him step down as possible
well we're doing an investigation I I
don't know the gentleman but I know
there have been problems and it's been
very unfair to the United States just
like the World Trade Organization has
been very very unfair and now they're
coming into line when they consider
China granted a developing nation and
because China is a developing nation
they take massive advantage of the
United States why did another president
stop this I've been talking about the WZ
and we're looking at that very very
strongly World Trade W so I have problem
with world health and world trade both
of them I'm not sure which is worse you
one another truth but we'll figure it
out okay
you were just criticizing the w-h-o for
praising China is transparent but you're
saying many of the same things about
China just a couple of months ago so I
mean how do you square your decisions
well I did a trade deal with China where
China is supposed to be spending two
hundred and fifty billion dollars and I
cannot be watching very much to see now
we've got a little bit waylaid by the
virus but look I'd love to have a good
relationship with China but if you look
and we made a phenomenal deal China has
paid because of me
China has paid us tens of billions of
dollars over the course of a very short
period of time
billions of it some of that money has
been spent to farmers where they were
targeted by China we cannot let that
happen we can't let that happen so we
ended up signing a very good trade deal
now I want to see if China lives up to
it I know President Xi I think he will
live up to it if he doesn't live up to
it that will be okay too because we have
very very good alternatives whu-oh but I
spoken hundreds of people across the
country in the last few weeks who say
they still can't get tested and that
they aren't social distancing because I
know I know your question
you read Eckerd death the governor's the
governors are supposed to do testing
it's up to the governor's go ahead
please
he's not going to the governor's are
doing the testing it's now not up and it
hasn't been up to the federal government
go ahead put this guy here it's nothing
but trouble he's a showboat if you keep
talking I'll leave and you can have it
out with the rest of these people if you
keep talking I'm gonna leave and you can
have it out with them
keep talking just a loudmouth are gonna
be running their individual states some
of them will say no I can't open now and
some of them may last longer than we
even would think others will say I can
you can go I don't want to mention
States but there are numerous states
that are in great shape right now
they're viewing the rest of the country
like we don't even believe this is
happening we have a lot of those things
open practically now I mean they would
be open now we're gonna let them open
sooner than the date we're gonna pick a
date we're gonna get a date that's good
but it's going to be very very soon
sooner than the end of the month but
there are many states out there that are
looking at this and they're reviewing it
and they're saying we shouldn't be even
included in this you know there's some
that want to open up almost now now if
we disagree with it we're not gonna let
them open we're not gonna let them open
if some governor said you know has a lot
of problems a lot of cases a lot of data
and they want to open early we're not
gonna let it happen
so we're there to watch we're there to
help but we're also there to be critics
and on testing very important we've
always wanted the states to do the
testing we're now providing great
testing but the state has to provide the
great testing the state has to provide
the ventilators but they didn't do that
so we ended up going into the ventilator
business essentially and we've made tens
of thousands of ventilators and we
solved a big problem for the states but
so we want them to do tens of thousands
of ventilators have not been
manufactured some ventilators have been
moved around some are starting to be
manufactured
to lie one question do you want to walk
back where you did praise China in
January for being transparent I'm always
respectful of China I'm respectful of
other countries why wouldn't I be
respectful of China in the meantime
China has paid us nothing in your last
administration nothing in any previous
administration they paid us tens of
billions of dollars because of what
we've done and the trade deal we have
they have to give us two hundred and
fifty billion dollars in purchases let's
see if they do that and they're also
paying us 25 percent of two hundred and
fifty billion dollars a territory so
we're taking in our companies we take it
in billions of dollars for China from
China they never paid us ten cents
that's a great thing now if they don't
produce or if we find out bad things
we're not gonna be happy but right now
and and we're doing that that's what
we're doing look we have an
investigation underway we're paying
almost 500 million dollars we have an
investigation underway on the World
Health Organization not the question we
will find out exactly what went on and
we may be satisfied that it could be
remedied and we may be said of satisfied
that is so bad that it can't be remedied
and if it can't we're going to go a
different route
for praising China for being transparent
but you also praise China for being
transparency well you know if I'm so
good to China how come I was the only
person the only leader of a country that
closed our borders tightly against China
and by the way when I closed up order
that was long ahead of what anybody you
can ask anybody that was in the room 21
people I was the one person that wanted
to do it Deborah can tell you that
better than anybody I was the one person
that wanted to do it you know why
because I don't believe everything I
hear and I closed and if we didn't close
our border early very early long before
the kind of dates you're talking about
we would have had thousands and probably
hundreds of thousands more death very
strong
oh no it's being worked on Deborah we're
working on that very strongly
okay CTC is working but we're getting
reports on that yeah you know some
countries haven't I'm watching other
countries I'm studying other countries
as they don't get to the point I don't
want to go into names because for some
it would be a little bit embarrassing
but I'm studying other countries as we
go along so on that we have looked at
every country that's opened some
successfully some okay no total disaster
but some okay and some have to go back
to the hot spot and fix the hot spot we
think we're going to do it very
successfully again we have one country
but we have lots of different pieces
it's a puzzle we have beautiful pieces
beautiful states with capable governors
they know when it's time to open and we
don't want to put pressure in anybody
I'm not going to put any pressure on any
governor to open I'm not going to say to
Governor Cuomo you got to open within
seven days I want him to take his time
do it right and then open New York I'm
not putting any pressure on the
governor's
some of them don't need pressure or not
pressure I mean they're ready to they're
ready to go and that's a good thing so
we'll open it up in beautiful little
pieces as it comes along it would be
[Music]
king you know I heard he said that but I
didn't I didn't see the remarks but he
understands how we helped him he needed
help
we gave him 2900 funny acting like
because he helped States they have to do
what he says no the federal government
is supposed to be there to help States
and emergencies the federal government
has no constitutional authority to tell
States what to do in the opening verses
closing sense
it's just unrelated things but if you do
we're gonna have them built it's all
quid pro quo with Trump tastic job and
the US Navy did a fantastic job when we
moved the ship that was not meant for
kovat and we had it redesigned for kovat
but they still didn't have very many
people going in now we are will get
along just fine he understands we'll get
along just fine please
a lot of shy are you sure workers in
states that may reopen poke up this
letter with your assurance the workers
well that's gonna be up to the
governor's the governor's are gonna want
to make sure everything's safe now I
think that companies can do testing on a
maybe weekly basis you have to do it
every day with the same worker
well they need what they can do testing
they could do temperature gauges they
could do a lot of different things and
you know we're only talking about for a
period of time you know eventually we
want to get back so guys the Matt if
Trump Trump suggesting weekly testing I
love it you need 44 million tests a day
to do that you need 44 million tests a
day we don't have 44 million tests today
it's a great idea test weekly but in
order to test every seven days you need
44 million tests we have 300 reporters
in the back that want to say look at the
look at this the way this looks I don't
even like the way it looks although I
have a lot fewer reporters that's okay
with me but look at the way this looks
I've never seen anything John I've never
seen anything quite like it
but there are a lot of time we don't
want this I don't want this I don't want
this eventually we're going back where
restaurants that had 150 seats are going
to have a hundred and fifty seats not 50
seats because they can't make it at 50
seats but more importantly the
atmosphere is even better we have to get
used to it we have to get used to I
don't know other people are gonna be
shaking hands as readily some will I
said to some of the hospital people
today so well people be shaking hands
again and I must say I was a little
surprised most of them said probably
because there is some kind of a thing to
it I was never a big hand shaker but
when I ran for politics I said I think I
better start shaking people's hand yeah
go ahead John mr. president a couple of
financial questions if I could
Larry Kudlow said this morning that at
the current run rate the paycheck
protection money will run out very soon
plan to re-up it is stalled in Congress
what can you do as president truck to
try to move that forward well we're
trying to get it done the problem is the
Democrats want to put all sorts of
things less time to put Kennedy Center
and I hated putting Kennedy Center and
I've great respect for Kennedy Center
but I hated putting
in the bill because it's just not
appropriate right and but they wanted it
in for whatever reason they had their
own political reason and Jen I said
watch the way that blows up and it blew
up I think it blew up in their face
we want to take care of our workers
we'll worry about other things and other
pet projects of Democrats and also
Republicans later but it's been a
tremendously successful program I think
you see if they banks have stepped up
hundreds of thousands of loan
applications you money money is going
out it's been a tremendous program
really has been and obviously it was at
a point where we're almost you know
we're almost the money will be expired
and we could use a refill for the
workers we want to be able to make sure
that small businesses stay open John
Goble and I think that'll happen yeah go
ahead
said earlier that there were as many as
20 states that could reopen their
economies as it really is May 1st no I
didn't say all of them by May 1st but
there are 20 states actually I was given
a number 29 states are in very very good
shape I don't want to say whether or not
the governor spoke with me about that
but we've had a very good relationship
Gavin Newsom and very very good
relationship behind the back go ahead
questions one question but that there's
a danger that there that the food supply
could be interrupted during this endemic
and I don't know what you're going to do
about well I think our farmers are
incredible they're producing levels of
food like just unbelievable much
education that's one of the reasons I
have the transportation people on the
line tomorrow for the delivery of the
food now we're doing phenomenally with
the food and I will say the stores
Kroger and Walmart which has a lot of
the food and and then you know grocery
stores don't produce the food does he
know that better be very strong on food
supply
okay how about one more question go
ahead please yes the death projections
that you mentioned earlier are based on
full social distancing until the end of
yeah so if you
he's up in these guidelines now how many
more Americans do you think well I'm not
easing up first of all will have
guidelines even for the state said open
and there'll be guidelines but we will
not have any problem with that where
your questions a very interesting
question but the states that are opening
are not States which will have a problem
with that plus he will have to adhere to
guidelines until a certain point into
the future when the enemy is vanquished
they don't have is partially and some of
that will stay in effect much of it will
stay in effect for a period of time but
the reason also is there different kinds
of states they have lots of room they
have fewer people and they have lots of
room and that's one of the primary
reasons I want to thank you all very
much so a lot of positive things are
happening we're gonna have some very
strong recommendations for the
governor's we're going to work with the
governor's the governor's are gonna do a
good job and if they don't do a good job
we're gonna come down on them very hard
we'll have no other choice thank you all
very much thank you thank you so we do
not have the tests we need unfortunately
we need one 222 million tests a day to
really be able to safely reopen
I so appreciate everybody who joins me
for these streams all ten or eleven
thousand of you today across our various
platforms because if you weren't here I
would just be some not yelling at the TV
and that would be so ugly for so many of
us if you're heading out on YouTube
please do make sure to hit that
subscribe button on the way out you'll
be notified when we do these streams in
the future I do appreciate it also a
huge thank you to the 65 of you that
made a pledge on patreon
today pledges ranged from $1 to $100 a
month
patreon comm slash david pakman show is
the place to do it
we will keep streaming these and doing
the best job I can in live fact-checking
I'm only one person but I do the best I
can and per capita seems to be a play a
major role from the standpoint of
fact-checking but in all seriousness
thank you for joining me consider even a
dollar a month pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we have new
clips going up on YouTube
for the rest of the evening you can
always get the podcast on iTunes or
whatever podcast program you use to get
our full hour show every day and take
the twenty second viewer survey at david
pakman.com slash survey we just want to
know how affected by the virus you are
and you can take that survey at david
pakman.com slash survey talk to y'all
tomorrow thank you
you